hi welcome to man carrying thing today i
am carrying
book el doctoros ragtime
i am a massive fan of this author this
book
may have single-handedly saved me from
going a life
of non-reading when i was in college
or i took a a year gap year wasn't
reading very much
at my local library i found a copy of
ragtime which just sounded interesting
it just struck me in the opening lines
patriotism was a reliable sentiment in
the early 1900s teddy roosevelt was
president the population customarily
gathered in great numbers either out of
doors for parades public concerts fish
fries political picnics
social outings or indoors and meeting
halls vaudeville theaters operas
ballrooms there seemed to be no
entertainment that did not involve great
swarms of people
this is a book that puts you in a time
and place that does not exist and may
have never existed
it is a fascinating novel that
connects real people with fictional
people there were multiple times while i
was reading this when i had to
google certain people to try to figure
out okay is this a real person
or is this a fictional character and
some of these people i was surprised to
find out were
real this is my first time i learned
about emma goldman the famous
anarchist she has a significant role in
this harry houdini
is in the first scene he drives he
crashes his car in front of these
this character's house it is a very fast
read
it's written in a way i saw some critic
try to describe it as just like kind of
like this this machine gun fire just
these short
snappy sentences that's just to the
point this this and this
and this happen i mean there's a huge
cast of characters you're jumping from
henry ford has a little vignette to
[ __ ] the rich guy what's his name you
know these rich
tycoons of the era and and their weird
obsessions and fantasies and
henry ford wasn't particularly weird to
to be around and interact with and then
you have these
regular fictional characters who are
dealing with various
problems the issues of of race are
hugely important in this novel and
oppression and this kind of double-sided
world of wealthy people
and those who aren't in this kind of
schism in
in these characters lives very radical
times
in which so much progress is occurring
so much
so many new things there are characters
threads that are just
gorgeous and breathtaking and brilliant
tragic
and ominous and in certain ways
thrilling and then
punctured by these little vignettes with
people we know harry houdini henry ford
point is this book is just
insanely entertaining it's sort of like
fantasy
if you could call it that's like
historical fantasy in a sense because
there's real people but fictional events
it's a really unique and exciting way to
experience history it's a unique and
exciting way to
experience a novel i was in such a
reading slump i had
not read since high school i was really
just away from books in a really
unhealthy way that was making me unhappy
and this was
the book that that pulled me out of that
that snapped me out of that because
it had this whole this electric writing
quality
that just engaged me instantly i've
since
read other books by el doctoro his short
story collection the
lives of the poet which was great except
for the the title
story which is unfortunately the longest
i didn't like that one but
his short stories are very good the
waterworks which
is great it's very much like an edgar
allen poe story
written in a style of a book that would
have been written in the early
mid 1800s and it's kind of like a spooky
science fiction tale in a sense billy
bathgate is one that's
famous turned into a movie i actually
dnf'd that uh
it was just like a gangster story about
a kid and a gangster and i didn't love
it just didn't interest me i also dnf'd
homer and langley which is kind of
another
fictional account of real people
regardless of those two dnfs
still a great writer the books were
still enjoyable i just for whatever
reason
other stuff got in the way i just didn't
feel the need to finish them felt like i
got what i could out of them that was
different with ragtime where ragtime
i was pulled clear to the end i was
caring about these characters
and you know overjoyed with each new
weird vignette with
actual historical people first off i
just think this era of history is really
interesting the turn of the century the
early 1900s and through this lens of
fiction and mythology it's it really
is a joy to read if you enjoy history
if you enjoy fantasy honestly i suggest
reading ragtime
that's my take i know this is kind of a
short short and sweet video i just
wanted to share this book that is very
personal to me it's one of my favorites
and i i think um
yeah i think people will enjoy so thanks
for watching if you're new to the
channel
like and subscribe smash that freaking
like button
bye